Der Gipfel Göbsi bei Gonten mitten in
der Schweiz.
1.200 Höhenmeter, zwei Künstler,
ein Berg und ein Bett.
Unter freiem Himmel steht ein Hotelzimmer,
das ganz ohne Dach und Wände auskommt:
das Null-Stern-Hotel – ein Konzept der
Künstler-Zwillinge Frank und Patrik Riklin.
Beim Null-Stern-Hotel da ist ja
genau das Interessante,
dass viele Leute nicht mehr wissen,
was es jetzt ist.
Ist es jetzt Kunst, ist es Tourismus,
ist es Innovation?
Das ist eigentlich das
Spannende daran,
dass wir die Leute auch ein
bisschen verunsichern.
Keine Wandtapete, sondern die
grandiose Kulisse rund ums Bett
zieht Menschen aus der ganzen Welt an.
Wir haben dieses Bett inszeniert,
gebaut und dann eröffnet,
und ab dem Moment war es
eigentlich voll gebucht.
Das ist eben der Witz dieser Umdrehung:
Null Sterne bedeutet ja nicht
Verzicht auf Luxus,
sondern eben das Erfahren eines
anderen, neuen Luxus.
Hier im Appenzellerland
hatte Almbauer Köbi Dietrich
bisher wenig mit Kunst zu tun.
Jetzt ist er mittendrin –
als Empfangschef und Butler.
Jeden Abend nach dem Kühemelken
wird der Almwirt Teil des Kunstprojektes.
Die Idee war: Wie kann man ein Konzept,
das natürlich Kunst ist,
ins Leben rufen
und [wie können] die Spieler, die Player,
also die Menschen, die um dieses Kunstwerk
leben, Teil davon werden?
Ohne ihn wäre das viel zu klassisch,
also er springt eigentlich oder hüpft oder …
… schlüpft …
… schlüpft eigentlich in dieses
Kunstwerk hinein.
Also wenn man jetzt als Künstler spricht,
ist Null Stern wie ein Bild, das aber lebt.
Ein einsamer Almbauer, der hier im
Sommer mit Frau, Kindern und Kühen lebt,
bekommt urplötzlich jeden
Tag neuen Besuch
und er genießt es – erstaunlicherweise.
Rund 260 Euro kostet die
Freiluftübernachtung
mit Bergblick und Frühstück.
Die neuen Gäste kommen.
Die beiden Freunde leben in Genf
und haben eine kurzfristig frei werdende
Nacht ergattern können.
Und sie sind die ersten Gäste, die die
Künstler hier persönlich treffen.
Ich denke, das ist die beste
Idee auf der ganzen Welt. Es ist toll.
Und so fühlen sich die beiden
schnell heimisch.
Schon schwebt Raphael Tammans
Drohne über ihnen,
um das Alpenfeeling festzuhalten.
Es ist genial. Ich war’s, der dir gesagt
hat, wir sollen hierherkommen.
Wer kann schon so einschlafen,
inmitten der schönsten Berge der Welt
mit einem solchen Sonnenuntergang?
Ich kann es noch nicht realisieren.
Ich denke, ich brauche ein wenig Zeit.
Es ist unwirklich.
Das Fernsehprogramm: Wetterprognose,
Witze oder Musik, analog von
Mensch zu Mensch.
Künstlerische Kritik am
Digitalisierungswahn.
Der einzige Star hier ist der Gast.
Das ist die Null-Stern-Philosophie.
Wenn man sieht, wie die Leute
dann reagieren,
wie sie in diesem Kunstwerk dann eben
sich auch bewegen und begeistert sind,
dann begeistert das auch uns selber.
Also, wir merken dann,
dass dieses Konzept lebt.
Am Morgen kommt der Regen.
Die Gäste müssen in die
Ersatzunterkunft umziehen
in die Almhütte von Bauer Köbi Dietrich.
Zum Frühstück gibt es Eier, Milch
und Schinken vom Hof.
Auch alles andere kommt aus der Region.
Es ist ein Traum,
und dann wird man morgens wach,
und es ist kein Traum.
Das war schon eine Erfahrung.
Ich habe unglaublich gut geschlafen,
das Bett war superbequem.
Es war angenehm. Es gab ein paar Mücken,
aber man gewöhnt sich dran.
Kommerzielle Angebote für ihr Konzept –
sogar einen Millionendeal
– haben die Künstler abgelehnt.
Wie es weitergeht mit dem Null-Stern-Hotel,
lassen sie offen.